a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo io sono parigi oggi siamo con un
ospite d'eccezione che sul mio cancro
non si è visto surreal power ciao maria
a questo contesto comunque le poltrone
il red bull è tutto molto tutto molto
serio c'è questo sito che
sostanzialmente è un intelligenza
artificiale
inserisci una frase è questa indecenza
tct artificiale chi genera delle
immagini di questa frase che tu stai
mettendo che non esistono le genera ad
hoc in base a quello che stai pensando
proviamo a farla tipo ragno gigante che
cammina a central park
spero che ci sia un ragno enorme che
esce dallo schermo e ti vengono in
fatica
mamma mia ragazzi terrificante me è
bellissimo
bene tra gli sto schifo clamoroso non
voglio più vedere liszt scimmia con
valigetta
sotto la torre eiffel ma vengo a fuoco
tensio attenzio veli bellissimo il
temuto perfetta ma scusa vendiamoli come
in effetti
io non so cosa tu fichera i dentro non
lo so vedo solo immagini devo capire
cosa è successo possiamo partire ma
prima di partire
lo sponsor di oggi prima di cominciare
ragazzi parliamo dello sponsor di oggi
che è
e lo flash mi manda una boxe a casa ogni
settimana con all'interno ingredienti
sempre freschi per realizzare nelle
ricette super gustose di vostra scelta
ovviamente quella scheda passo passo per
realizzarle il menù cambia ogni
settimana potete adattarlo voi alle
vostre preferenze o ordinato la mia
ragazzi che è arrivata praticamente oggi
è la de scatolero nel video tra l'altro
mi hanno fornito all'attrezzo del cato
lante che non è si usa questo per aprire
le scatole però vabbè
ragazzi questo apre i pacchi non sapete
ancora niente nella vita nemmeno io
quanto pare per avremo la scatola ci
troviamo davanti a le ricette appunto
che ho ordinato e ovviamente qua ci sono
tutti i passaggi con i vari ingredienti
spiegati che vi spiegano come realizzare
appunto le varie ricette probabilmente
dopo questo video a pranzo angolo di
hamburger di manzo alle erbe che questo
qua proviamo ad e scatolare lo se
apriamo la scatola con sacchetto
italiano importante centro
abbiamo il prezzemolo ovviamente quello
di gardaland peperoncino questo questo
pesante questo vale in testa del
peperoncino in questo momento ma serve
più tardi abbiamo ovviamente il fan e
per l'hamburger sono due va beh sì certo
se mangio in compagnia ma io vivo da
solo quindi mai a due hamburger
ragazzi essere single ovviamente il
macinato di bovino che è nel sacchetto
per i cibi freschi grande sud i fiori
sono molto contento ragazzo di tutto
questo perché finalmente non sembrano un
pirla in cucina ma solo perché mi
spiegano passo passo le cose se volete
provarlo ragazzi vi lascio il link qua
in descrizione mi lascio anche il mio
con i suoi scontro dove potete avere
fino a 65 euro di sconto sulle prime tre
moto ringrazialo fresh per aver
sponsorizzato questo video direi che
possiamo partire
ok ragazzi siamo tornati elio in realtà
ho già inserito nell'albo ritmo alcune
alcune frasi e vorrei che partisse
rolando così neanche io so di preciso
cosa vice i partner starei diciamo siamo
noi letteralmente adesso è più o meno
non c'e la palma grande e
bellissima allora complimenti perché
grazie tu faccia a farsi venire cercherò
probabilmente nella sua stessa posizione
babbo natale gaga
ok mentre
li ha in mano parte che li sta cagando
in mutande li sta cagando quei pantaloni
e questa cosa non ha senso li sta
cagando concesso chiuso il più accurato
è il secondo con cui l'unico con cui
forse puoi capire il secondo babbo
natale fa uno sforzo immane per però
spetta facendo uno sforzo in maniche di
ci sono delle scie luminose gialle
perché sta facendo quello sforzo immane
ricorda la tua infanzia cosa cosa
succedeva a cosa facciamo delle strisce
gialle luminose atto da una persona mia
madre di sparavano raggirati da quando
prendevo 2 a scuola ok babbo natale
diventa super sayan mentre è successo il
secondo si è avvicinato molto a chi c'è
l'altro licola sta facendo si sta
tirando una striscia di coca cola ora
son curioso
allora non è palesemente lago di como di
cosa si va quindi hai scritto
l'agricoltura coin roma lei amici vanno
in barca sul lago di como esatto gli
extra smetti di muoverti questo sembra
che ti muovi
come ho detto no no
questo è clamorosa voglio dire la tua
reazione quando tg rai
[Risate]
beh io non so neanche se fine ci pensa
nemmeno tu mi possa dire ma per favore
ma chi
bellissimo quello no non sa neanche da
dove partire pontefice emirato arabo più
vero la prima rosa pestino
sull'elicottero
barca a ibiza
brown ha detto papà a festa su uno yacht
che bulla con delle belle ragazze
queste le prime due sono
delle prime due sarebbe calabrese questa
è venuta dal dio che vive qui e sono le
secolo spread per questo poi ti faccio
vedere questa
eccolo
quest'anno non c'entra niente con tutto
il mio esatto qual è la pubblicità di
leroy merlin prodotto allora folletto
diciamo che in rosa poi
principessa si
principessa registra un video sì ma
perché siamo un trapano mentre a
principessa si fa a trapanare mentre uno
riprende
c'è un trapano a noi a you tube può fare
un video mentre un muratore in anno con
una gonna rosa usa il trapano
principessa si fa trapana con vlc media
player e faccio una io vai da devi
indovinare buy
[Musica]
qualcosa mi dice che in qualche modo
dovrei essere io cosa che ho in mano
della prima cosa che faccio con le mani
addosso tipo orologi giganti azzurri che
vai scalare un vulcano come un orologio
una camicia
velato con camicia e
anche le mani no ho scritto l'uomo
velato con occhiali da sole con un
vestito di bianco lancia il suo rolex
dorato nel vulcano nel mercato perso
solo che non lo leggo
però non è male c'è questo 6 palesemente
più tra 30 anni 6 tuta tuta almeno
pelato
il nostro algoritmo che si chiama paolo
generale le immagini che noi dovremo
indovinare quindi vediamo quello è jaden
e santo questo è un filmone verificate
questa cosa che questi sono delle
galline suore in discoteca giusto si è
dominato
credibile lo so perché il mio sogno
erotico eretico e è c'è
questo e rugosa in cervi nel parco the
raven 21 di per denaro non lo so
perché c'è quel foglietto che le sta
vendendo con un tablet non lo so ai tipo
il mio amazon eccola la fattura suoi
esordi e sta vendendo se i cervi questo
è il parco del re su ebay per che cosa
facendo sull'età col tablet se i mali
non essere un tablet che è tutta una
postazione via invece come sia da questa
supermercato un cervo due cervi ragazzi
io direi che possiamo comunque che se
portando avanti tutto il giorno
questo è questo è quanto vi ringrazio
per aver visto il video ringrazio suri
ciao ragazzi ci diamo un'immagine che
dovete indovinare voi nei commenti
[Musica]